- Many private universities
depend heavily on blank,
the wealthy individuals who support them
with gifts and bequests.
So whatever blank is,
they're kind of saying
well, another way of
describing blank is that
they're the wealthy
individuals who support them
with gifts and bequests.
So which of these words are the best
or best represent wealthy individuals
who would support a private university
with gifts and bequests?
So the instructors, they
would teach at the university,
but they don't tend to be wealthy,
and they don't tend to
be giving large gifts
or even be giving gifts at all.
They take a salary from the university.
So I would rule out the instructors.
The administrators, well
these are the people
who kind of run the
university, but once again,
they don't tend to be wealthy,
and they don't tend to give
gifts to the university,
donate money to the university.
So I will rule that out.
Monitors, well the monitor is
something that would mean to
kind of observe something,
see what's going on.
That doesn't really mean
giving to something.
So I would rule that out.
Accountants, well these are the people
who take account of things.
They're the ones who kind
of keep track of the books,
who keep track of the
money for any organization,
in this case maybe
university, but once again,
they're not the wealthy individuals
who would support the university
with gifts and bequests.
So I'd rule those out.
So, I've ruled out all the choices,
so we should hope that it's
going to be benefactors,
and benefactors makes
sense, because notice,
it has the word bene.
Well, you don't see
exactly the word benefit.
You see the word benefact,
but it's really coming
from the word benefit,
and if you're benefiting someone,
that means you're doing
something for them.
So a benefactor is someone
who's doing something
for, in this case, a private university.
So I would definitely go with benefactors,
and you could put it back in the sentence
and see that it actually
sounds quite right.
Many private universities
depend heavily on benefactors,
the wealthy individuals who support them
with gifts and bequests.
You could almost say,
many private universities
depend heavily on benefactors,
the wealthy individuals who benefit them
with gifts and bequests.